hey what's up party people welcome to
honest trailer commentaries a day late
but not a joe short uh we're talking
about vox machina today uh from the
critical role folks uh and featuring
matthew mercer and we're featuring joe
starr who really uh took the lead on
writing this one as our uh resident uh d
d expert though as i say resident uh joe
you have some news to share with the
people watching
yeah i'm now you're visiting d d expert
yeah uh
if you saw this morning we've been uh
we've been bought by daddy d d
uh uh super stoked
um gonna go figure out where i put my
toothbrush uh now that we're moving in
together uh very excited about that so i
but i i also can't think of a more
fitting sort of like last thing to do
with the gang than a dnd on his trailer
with a roadhouse joke in it so can you
put your wrist back on camera are you
are you going have you been bitten by a
steampunk vampire
i have
look behind me it's nothing but whiskey
and d books
i remember i have big changes
you've changed
i have axes now yes
change the pandemic has changed me man
i love this oh
yeah i'm literally like moving like old
vodka bottles from drunk stream so i'm
like oh that shouldn't be on camera so
it's changed
well the rest of us have gone goblin
mode joe has only become the the gnome
prince who was promised
[Laughter]
everything's leather-bound the entire
apartment now every
yeah the cats uh both
in ac-11 leather armor
sorry i want to d and d jokes
no plea this is the time form i'm gonna
sort of semi-recuse myself because
here's the thing um i i enjoyed this
show uh really appreciated it thought it
was funny throughout uh never played d
and d and uh didn't watch uh critical
role i like what i've seen but that's
why we had to call the big guns um joe
uh give us a little bit of the backstory
of where where the show comes from and
what it's all about
yeah so uh so uh
critical role uh is a uh a group that
started uh a group of uh voice actors
there there were pals that started
streaming d and d
games i don't know
ten years ago nine
uh a while back and it was their
personal game like it wasn't like it was
one of those things where they were like
this is a money grab we could make money
they just like it already they're doing
it for the love games yeah yeah and i
think felicia day was like you won't put
that on camera and they were like okay
uh it really took off
uh obviously
um and uh so this show is an adaptation
of their very first they're on cam their
third campaign right now this this show
is an adaptation of their very first
campaign and i think a lot of stuff that
they had played through together before
the
before they started live streaming their
games
um
and uh yeah it's just like
uh matt the the dm who also you know
appears in in the trailer it's his world
um and uh yeah so it's really taken off
to me i think
i don't know i it's either a really cool
uh you remember when like in the 90s
when image launched and all of a sudden
there are all these cool creator-owned
comics to me it's like it's either
maybe they're the the the pioneers of
creator-owned like
ip and stuff like that or just studios
will learn the wrong lesson from this
and uh buy every d stream they can get
their hands on but you know everybody
get your money the great thing about
this is that they like keep going and
don't like suddenly just stop doing
things yeah uh joe kiew i'm talking to
you
battle chasers you should have finished
it again wow this is a really niche
episode of this show let's talk 90s
creator-owned comics
i apologize
uh there were a lot of pouches on this
show i think this also highlights what's
so hard about making an official dance
as a dragon's adaptation and i'm not
trying to smirch joe i know there are
some in active development i'm sure
they're going to be great but i i like
it's so hard because d and d is less
like a world and more like a platform
for making your own world which is
exactly what
mercer and the critical role team have
done and that this show highlights so
well which is a it is a d d show
there are jokes about the rules and
about how the game is played and like we
do even a run of like here are d d
tropes that you can see in the show but
it's also this original story about this
world and these characters it's not
dependent entirely on d d so i i don't
know how you do like dungeons and
dragons as a scripted series or as a
film
because there's already the potential to
do you know vox machina
yeah i and i'm hoping that like the
movie and stuff kind of follows suit
because like
um
even the original like 80s cartoon was
like these kids got on this amusement
park ride and uh oh they're wizards now
um
and uh so i'm i'm really i don't know i
i i'm hoping that they're not doing like
a jumanji uh with this uh where chris
pine's like okay fine i'll play your
silly game
[Music]
interesting yeah but if you take it
seriously and like not seriously but if
there's no meta aspect to it and you're
just in it then that seems like a video
game adaptation where like you've taken
away what makes it different and
interesting which is that like you're in
control and like there's it can depend
on the role of a guy
i almost feel like it's true the
difference between it's a dungeon it's a
dragon's movie versus it's like a dragon
lance movie like you could adapt the
stories of forgotten realms or like
there's books and there are
narratives out there but like that
wouldn't necessarily feel like
this is the dungeons and dragons movie
would just feel like this is a fantasy
story set in this specific world totally
i i think that it's the same thing as
like when they did final fantasy spirits
within which obviously like uh not only
did that thing but also like looked
really creepy and like weird um because
of the time but it's the same thing
where it's like we we like final fantasy
because like even if
and it's different from d and d because
in d you get to like i get to like make
my own character and like you know uh
decide
what i do when roman things but even in
final fantasy it's like i don't get to
make a choice now it's just like a bunch
of like weirdly stiff people
and occasionally you hit x yeah yeah you
hit x to skip the dialogue yeah um well
and yet this show managed to work so uh
may it be the template going forward and
yes may all the uh streamers get those
big checks um from from daddy bezos uh
let's start and stop as we go we'll
watch the honest trailer for box machina
critical role protocols fox mocking it
you be the judge let's go
invented by critical
[Music]
in a world where the only thing more
boring than someone telling you about
their dreams is someone telling you
about their dungeons and dragons
campaign one show will try to make those
dreams a little wetter
yeah
i mean i guess that's
much like
uh i'd say fantasy sports uh people's
dreams and improv comedy you had to be
there
you just had to be there
um because uh uh
also critical role is
for an outsider uh this was a actually
good introduction and actually went back
since watching this show to like a
random critical role stream and was like
oh this is fun i get it but like it's so
imposing to just start
uh something like that and it's like i
don't know i would not call it
accessible even for somebody who's like
nerd inclined but i would say that this
show is actually a good a good way in um
to this world
so well done
yeah i think that anyone that's into
fantasy obviously and we talk about this
later there are like these bits and bobs
where it's like you know it it's insider
stuff for those of us who know what
they're talking about but mostly on its
face it's like a fun cartoony
we talk about this super violent super
fun
um just like fantasy story that is set
up
in this world that has lore in the same
way that like everything that you love
has more um so yeah i i 100 agree um but
the tone of the show is determined by
those people like a different group of
people playing d and d would not have
the swears
and the and the yeah and the sex and
violence to that extent right yes you
could like role play it
very strange or you could have fun at
that time if goofy adults get together
yes it will end up being kind of like
this but yeah i i i get what you're
saying and i agree and i think one thing
the show does really well
i i was a little concerned that it would
be
two inside baseball like yeah you will
have to have seen a lot of critical role
to appreciate it and i it really is not
like i think they have a really good
balance of it captures the spirit
because i've seen some critical role but
not i'm certainly not like a regular
like i knew the whole story going in and
uh i think they did a really good job of
balancing like it's taking the spirit of
those games and the vibe of that these
uh voice actors had when they got
together but it's taking it and also
making it like a fantasy story that you
can just follow as a fantasy story
yeah uh well done all right keep playing
legend of vox machina
if you thought d d was a lot to absorb
strap in for an adaptation
put together by a group of nerdy ass
voice actors asking the most pressing
question of our time what a token
all brought to life by fans willing to
toss a coin to their twitchers in the
hopes that they'll pull off what hasn't
been done since clue and successfully
adapt a tabletop game to screen unless
you're into the battleship movie
uh pause
lon you were saying you recently
revisited battleship and it might be
very underrated uh oh very i would i did
not think very underrated
slightly somewhat underrated a few
things about the battleship movie one is
uh
they do a really uh uh
over the top more than they had to do
integrating elements of the game
battleship into the movie i thought
they're called
things
yes the alien missiles look like the
pegs from the game
their guidance systems go down they have
to use a grid
so they're like b6 and like that's where
they got like it like they do they do an
admirable job of working in tropes from
the game into the movie i also would say
it like the entire background cast like
everybody who has one or two lines every
like you know like ships mate or guy
running around in the background is now
famous like you got jesse fleming's back
there you got romney malek image link
layers in the background uh so it's fun
to go watch now because it's like a
who's who of who was doing bit roles 10
years ago in hollywood yeah even then
like rihanna was like famous but she
wasn't like i'm a billionaire with like
a huge makeup and she was like
sensational
yeah and it was i mean alexander
skarsgard uh liam neeson and rihanna
were like they were the stars and
everybody else
i'm sorry this is taylor kitchen erasure
no well he was still up and coaching
jesse clemens were just like on friday
night lights at this point and that's
why peter berg who was directing it like
that's how that came about so no he was
not like the marquee draw yet
this is a i didn't realize peter berg
made this one yeah yeah is he the guy
that's uh that's addicted to like uh
fashion
who's the guy that that made friday
night lights that like can't stop buying
leather coats oh peter berg i believe
that is peter burke he's the guy that
like he and mark wahlberg make every
movie about like a real guy trying to
blow something up and then mark wahlberg
stops him
yeah oh it's buzz buzz oh it's united
nope i won't make that joke um
like yeah they did you know it's those
two
awesome well a rewatch of battleship is
is definitely in the car it's on it's i
i watched it because it's on what it's
like on netflix or hbo max now or
something so it's out there that's why i
threw it up i didn't see it
gotcha
um
yeah the uh the um the guy who wrote the
book friday night lights uh buzz
bissinger um literally was addicted to
buying gucci coats and that's why it
went bankrupt
it's my strange addiction gucci goats
him and jared leto from that movie
there's a z
now that you're big time joe that's your
that like that is where you go next
you're just buying big leather goats
and leather
heads out there maybe dungeons and
dragons y2k how about the tom hanks one
why are you so impatient
because i love you and i want you to
forgive me yeah that's real and it's
spectacular
robbie you can't it's a trap
tj what am i doing
[Music]
pretty dark
an ale and meet box machina a ragtag
crew of mercs so horny and quippy joss
whedon is suing them for vibe
infringement not everything's a trap you
twitch let's do this
they're scanling the horny boy with a
tragic past who's master of the hand job
percy
are are bards really as useless in d as
they seem slashing everything anymore
role playing game not anymore okay
sorry i often play a bard so like this
is barter
it's fun it's a it's a fun kind of
character to play if you are as i used
to be if you are into it because you're
a ham and you like goofing around as
opposed to because you're really into
the game it's a fun role to have in the
party but you're not it's a lot less
like i'm gonna do a direct thing and
like save the day and more like i'm
gonna give this other player a little
like boost to their stats
yeah like that
again they like do a good job of
reflecting that in the show like a lot
more than scanlan is like i'm gonna come
in and kill the enemy and save the day
he's like i'm gonna throw the barbarian
into the bad guy so he can save the day
you know
got it joe what do you usually play when
you play uh do you do like a rosie or do
you do like a wizardy thing or what's
your usual
usually rogie i'm playing a paladin
right now uh on our dnd on stream and
it's very fun
very nice there you go the whole holy
man
um
i i respect it based on the spencer
knows that now
holy man
yeah well a tank here support person i
can mom-arm people it's fun
nice um wow this is great i should
someday some day when i have six hours
to spare i'll play dungeons and dragons
it takes six hours start to finish and
then you're done you've played it why do
you think this is where i am right now i
was like i really want to play this more
we're very busy with work what if
what if
like within a few months we're gonna
we're gonna log in for around australia
commentaries and spencer's just gonna
have leather-bound whiskey bottles
behind him i'll be like you got into it
you did it
he's gonna like roll for comment like
hey danielle you want a snark
sorry uh you ruled against me but you
rolled a crit one and like i rolled into
like i was on that path i think in in
you know about 10 11 years old i would
collect little pewter dragons with
little crystals on them and stuff like
that and there was there was a high
chance that um i would i would go down
that road but uh
yeah what it was stupid stupid
instruments and like uh friends
you know friends who are into the wrong
kind of thing not dungeons dragons
that's a that's a shame
drugs drugs
by that i mean yeah yeah you got but
they're not exclusive right are there
there's probably anyways we'll we'll
talk about that off camera okay uh are
there students who go to the euphoria
high school who were into dnd does that
exist there at all i went to the
euphoria
you think there's like three we there's
like three euphoria kids we don't ever
see on the show and they're just like uh
you know rolling for initiative in the
background
you know what i want to do is play uh
warhammer 40k i'm really intrigued by
the uh
the lord of that one
next time i run into you at trader joe's
i will have some minis for you
and you can
all right yeah you can paint them right
um
can't wait
all right uh let's keep going while i
just look at the title of different
warhammer books uh you guys can talk it
past who found himself in a fantasy
setting and asked why not try gun vex
and facts twins with a tragic past and
the power to make you constantly call
the show becks are vax machina by
mistake facts forms and backs facts box
facts vex vox max vox max vox works grog
an idiot with a tragic past he dum-dum
stupid you are hereby under house arrest
how can you arrest a house pike a cleric
with a tragic past and a direct line to
dnd jesus but since that's too powerful
they just sidelined her for half the
season i'm not going whoa
i have to do this alone caleb a tree
hugger with a tragic
pause
there's that there's actually a a really
kind of clever critical role easter egg
in um
and her having to leave and get
sidelined for the season uh ashley
johnson who voices her
is
seems to be like i don't know like 40
busier than the rest of the cast at all
times and is always gone
and then she was also
gone for a ton of them making this
cartoon so in the game her characters
are always just like
i'll see you at the tower
you can go like i don't know voice
halo 6 through 15 or whatever yeah
that's uh eds so yeah it's like metal on
metal
yeah
yeah that's cool that that uh that
actually makes a a lot of sense but
again even if you don't know critical
roles specifically like that's a d and d
thing like not every adventurer is there
for every adventure because you know
sometimes the kids got a school play and
uh
um christopher's gone so we don't have a
healer right
believe me that is a very realistic dnd
from a lot of games once you're in your
late 20s and up
so as far as um
warhammer 40k novels should i start with
god blight
uh assassinatorium king maker
or crimson flats white scars omnibus
say this i have not delved into the
black library myself now my
understanding joe maybe you could shed
light on this it's like
knowingly
with a wink grim dark right like i think
it's not it was supposed to be i think
it was supposed to be a wink at some
point and i think at some point it just
became group target
because the warhammer stuff is such a
it's so it's so grim dark that you
really have to read it as like it's it's
knowingly like we're yeah
but if you would
if you jump in there you'll have to tell
me
yeah
well when i will give you a full book
report next time you're here on a
crimson fist the omnibus yeah i'll tell
you everything about the crimson fists
and their defense of rin's world i just
it's put away but i i just got this
ridiculous like demon model that's like
this big uh it's put away damn i was
gonna pull it out so you could sing a
metal song about it without your demon
oh yeah we gotta do a metal song uh
before you go all right uh let's keep
playing who's also a jewish princess
filled with ashari i'm supposed to lead
someday funny she doesn't look jewish
and a bear with what i can only assume
is a tragic past a well-adjusted bear
just takes his chances in the woods
right together they'll win glory
also gets sidelined like i feel like
there are a lot of moments where a bear
would have come in handy that they
forget they have a bear they violate the
rule of chekhov's bear which i feel like
this is one thing this soon after drive
my car it's like chekhov was very clear
about this
[Laughter]
affair
i didn't watch this campaign i haven't
watched the vox machina campaign uh but
uh people in the comments are saying
that yes the bears pass is actually as
sad as [ __ ] so
yeah and that's the thing it's um
i actually looked into it that they
don't they don't show everybody's tragic
past completely but just in a quick
fandom
look up uh everybody's got a tragic past
yeah
that's a dnd thing in general like no no
one's ever been like here's my
well-adjusted person that's just gonna
go on a weird quest like everybody's if
i tell you write a character with a
backstory there's got to be some some
conflict in there they're going to be
like tragedy you're not just going to
write you know
he had 17 parents and they were all
murdered
that might be my character how much
nepotism baby
i've played a number baby i'm sorry i
was a bard what else was i supposed to
do i totally played baby yeah my
character is judd apatow's son
one kid who played
i had to audition okay
you know i was just like elizabeth
berkley and saved by the bell no one
knew that
dad but i like being playing a guy like
uh like uh peter in deadpool 2 or i saw
a listing for adventure uh yeah yeah
i've got an opening i mean i thought
it'd be this would be a fun character
nobody has not been tried a lot yeah
all right let's keep going and fame by
uncovering an ancient secret the beast
is a blue dragon sire how do we fight it
there's no simple way to kill a dragon
did gilmore give you any insight on how
to kill this thing the only way to kill
a dragon is to hit it in the throat the
knack you see that no one thought to try
that before i mean dragons are like 20
throat is there no roadhouse cooler
class in this edition
swayze man now that's a character with
high charisma joe you did it you mad man
you finally got
the roadhouse throat rip i did and you
know what i'll say this if
i
by our rules of just editing and keeping
things a little more tight i feel like
it would have cut after um
was there no cooler class and we
wouldn't have done the clip but
i like to think that you gave me this
one
100 you know i'm not going to
go out without a throat rip
does this mean my final honest trailer
we're going to do an x versus sever
reference is that where ballistic
finally gets
[Laughter]
i was like writing this one in my head i
think as i wrote it or as we watched it
because that's the curse of doing this
show
uh and i think that was like joke number
one i was like roadhouse dragon and then
joke number two was jewish princess
baseball's clip
nice
uh all right uh yeah we'll do a
roadhouse honest trailer on a long
enough timeline everything everything
gets won
is the movie the week after i leave i
swear to god
we're already planning we're already
like joe's gone now
yeah transformers movie was one for
people who haven't paid too much
attention is that's been on the schedule
maybe more than anything else because
it's like all right we'll give joe this
one and then for whatever reason
i think it'd be fun but literally
something bigger has happened that week
every time almost every time yeah
there's always a money plane that just
cries out for attention i think it is
transformers of the movie is the lindsay
buckingham dispenser is what up with
that
[Laughter]
one day one day
uh okay let's keep going
take a chance and roll the dice on a
series aimed at everyone from fans of
invincible defense of buying sorts from
the skymall catalog
continues his getting back in my boy's
investment spree with plenty of catnip
for die hards while sneaking so much
actual d d into the script you'll feel
like you're eating lunch alone in 8th
grade again from references to spell
cooldown rules and i think i can only do
it like once a day having to shop for
supplies before an expedition we will
take all the holy water you've got
you're looking at it
you're annoying buddy who comes up with
a super long name and expects everyone
to use it i am lord percival frederick
steinver musel kolowski darulo the third
the uselessness of bards what if i lure
the guards away from the house yeah good
one come on real ideas
the true big bad evil guy of every
single rpg of all time
doors it's just a damn door
it's not open the door it's not a door
it's a thing of evil
yeah that's uh that translates to uh
online rpgs and really any video game
it's always like you can't get past this
door for some reason i i'm sad to see
that that's also the way of uh stopping
your progress in dnd yeah of course oh
as a
as a dungeon master yeah this is if
there's a door and everyone is
immediately just like my god and it's
like
just turn the knob and open it there's
so much
there's so much is that just like to
delay is that just to lengthen the play
time or like give the dungeon master no
i think prepper
no i think because i'll oh i'll have
prepped and it's like there's so i i
prepped for 10 hours on the other side
of this door please just open the
[ __ ] door it's not locked it's just a
door but i think naturally like as
players we're always just like my god
hey joe this couldn't be a normal door
would you can i roll for insight
yes on dnd beyond uh yeah so i'm rolling
for insight um i have rolled a two
um joe is there anything else in the
hallway that i could possibly roll that
i could see if there's anything
just this big sign that says it's just a
door push it
it's not even enough
uh so can i take off the sign and like
see if there's anything behind me well
isn't that kind of on the dm for not
making it into like a beaded curtain or
something no they do
they do we're just all [ __ ] that's
my fix from now on
it's like kind of a tropical like a like
a hawaiian looking
into this beaded curtain to separate it
it's something that a trap
joe if i turn this knob is it actually a
shape shifter who has turned himself
into a knob yeah like we don't yeah
no yeah it yeah no i guarantee if it was
beaded curtains everyone would be like
are the beads sentient are they gonna
wrap around me am i gonna die
be the constrictor yeah that sounds fun
um
i think that here's a here's a
prediction here's a hot take uh this is
going to be
uh
more well received uh this show is gonna
do better for amazon than lord of the
rings than their lord of the rings
series i'm i'm calling it oh i know it's
bold but i think that it's not
i i had semi-high hopes i know it's
completely different companies and stuff
like that until i saw a halo on
paramount and i'm like oh
when you don't get it and you don't have
any of the people involved that made it
good
fans are not going to follow you there
and this is i mean
i think in this case for better but for
better or worse a lot of the time this
is for fans and it definitely pleases
the hell out of everybody watch it learn
the rings i think i will say
lord of the rings they they have gotten
the hell out of the third age so
we don't really know that much about the
time they're exploring like if you're a
very very high i don't know good scholar
you know about the second age but most
of us it's vague whereas halo they're
just rewriting the core storyline
from the games themselves and it's like
i don't think that they will they don't
have to come back because they're
putting it wrong
i just feel like that feels like a
bigger violation
they're still they're still hold over
characters it's not irwin but who's the
other elf no i mean there are
galadriel's gonna be in it and elrond's
gonna be in it and gandalf may show he's
alive i'm sure there's a gandalf there's
but like it's like set in like numenor
which is already underwater by the third
age like they're they're going pretty
outside and it'll be like young
good-looking sauron when he's still like
a person and like
i don't know i feel like that gives them
a little more creatively way if it's
good if it's bad then all bets are off
but like i think there's
halo is like what if this thing you love
was totally different and of course
that's gonna make people freak out
whether it's good or bad i was gonna say
so uh which uh i think i've asked this
before but i i still would like to know
so um who's in the lord of the rings
show are they gonna make black and piss
people off oh they yeah there's they
already have there's a few characters
one of them is an elf and that's what
set off people at first because elves
are pale they're ethereal yeah they're
like elves can't be black and it's like
oh all the elves you've met have been
white have they
yeah
elves don't have melanin or something
about it it's
if you've ever seen uh if you've ever
seen west side story you know that the
bose has learned how to make her skin
glow we can be ethereal if you just
moisturize and scrub now the whole
appendix of the silmarillion is all just
uh race science and the different
caliber measurements of people's skulls
it was written a long time
oh wait that's lovely
negro eggs man
um yeah lovecraft's a whole that's a
whole other candle yeah
um
anyways we won't gaze into that
i will say you know i i will say that
gandalf played by chris tucker is bold
yeah that would be amazing
do you understand the spells all right
let's
let's keep going let's keep going
not everything has to be a puzzle guys
we've been playing for six hours
straight and i want to go home
so gather around for a series that
recognizes the franchise potential of d
as an infinite story generator set in
hundreds of cool unique worlds this one
just happens to have lots of dick jokes
in it meticulously crafted dick jokes by
some of the greatest scribes in all the
land oh man mercer hey i love your best
thank you you uh you weren't talking
about my show were you uh just the usual
amount good otherwise you can expect
what my wife calls a good old-fashioned
paducah river strangle and then i'll
leave your body in orbit when bezos
takes me to space dude
i'm kidding it's me matt mercer the
nicest person in the world who is
definitely not a murderer anything else
while i'm here two things if you don't
mind where do all of your amazing ideas
come from well as a teenager i was
bitten by a radioactive van with a naked
wizard painted on the side also it never
hurts to have a little buzz going what's
the other thing uh i think i'm finally
ready to challenge you epic voice guy to
epic voice guy ah a worthy opponent you
know the rules best how do you want to
do this wins very well winner reads the
starring section
how do you want to do this how do you
want to do this how do you want to do
this
how do you want to do this how do you
want it dang it rolling that one well
played sir you can take it from here
stop all right pause um so
had this come about joe did you just ask
and he said yeah
pretty much uh
yeah no no pretty much um
uh
he's he's he's a super cool guy and is
always just kind of down to play a
little bit um
i think i wrote uh a first draft of this
where he was still his voice from the
spider-verse trailer because you know i
like canon a lot spencer and you know
this from jokes multiple things that
you've cut from scripts i've written
uh
uh and that got out of hand and then i
wrote uh a version with all of them
that i was gonna send to critical role
but then it was like six pages long and
that wasn't going to work uh
so you know i was like okay what do i
want to do i want to
make a space bezos space joke and i want
to get
old-fashioned river strangle into an
honest trailer at least once before i go
and uh
i feel like i feel like we've
accomplished
we've accomplished our goals nice yeah i
think this was perfect this is the uh
yeah
of course it would have probably been
cool to do a six-minute critical role
sketch or something like that but uh
yeah i never get to see that that sounds
fun too
that's how rough it was i was like i'm
not gonna send a spencer
uh but yeah i also props to kevin for
like visualizing that because i
didn't really explain i didn't give any
ideas i was not helpful
yeah no he's great he's right he he
finds everything he makes all that stuff
work uh it's great and yeah um
do we have any i wonder if we have any
outtakes of his session probably not but
he sent some alts and stuff yeah he sent
some really funny alts to the the bezos
space thing that were that were really
funny
yeah
uh nice well uh he seems great i'm glad
he glad he blessed us with the vo and
yeah like he did he up on the spider
verse trailer we had a few different
like other ver you know whatever
variants of the epic voice guy and and
matt was one of them he was one of them
friend of the show friend of the show
multiverse before everyone else
multiverse yeah we were there screw you
maguire we got there first
[Laughter]
all right uh let's keep playing grock
lesner vengeance for my family with a
pocket full of shells sharpest knife in
the drawer
elf with a shelf
this gnome gives dome
make like a tree and get out of here
cool youth pastor
sister so you have a twin sister your
feelings have not betrayed her too and
hey we saw you from across the tavern we
really dig your vibe
d and these nuts
hey you know if amazon doesn't play ball
keeping such a cool show around all good
this crew can actually crowdfund six
seasons in a movie and a follow-up video
game a live action movie and a making up
documentary
what's it like being loved this much
yeah man people really really love uh
this group and this show and uh just
seem happy to see it talked about
whereas i feel like they're a much
bigger deal than honest trailers so it's
like yeah we should be so lucky to uh to
glom onto them yeah they seemed very
excited about this and i was like why
why
a lot of a lot of them tweeted yesterday
like this is a real hollywood rite of
passage and it's like is it
i mean
whatever you say all right yeah it's
very much like you like me and you
really really love me
i think something cool about this and
this fan base that i think a lot of us
like older nerds are slow to pick up on
is that like this is a new generations
like dragon lance and lord of the rings
and raven loft you know all those
fantasy stories and books from like when
we were kids like this is theirs the
critical role is like
the new default like this is how i got
into this i feel like
this is bigger like this this generation
is more into it my generation there were
like three kids from every middle school
yeah yeah and they were the d hardcore
fans and everybody else was like
get out of here nerd and now it's like a
third of your class is like going to be
into some variation of tabletop gaming
and like right
and that's just like the the power of
social media to be able to um
in the way it both gives and takes it
gives for people where it's like hey
like my niche thing that like i thought
that i was like a nerd who was like
never going to be able to find friends
it turns out there are a million people
online who are really into my niche
thing and other people are like there
are a million people online who are into
my nation and it's like no not you
get off my niece
stay off my knees
yeah that's how we get the riddler
batman spoilers
and his
2 000 followers
nobody who knows how youtube works or
tick tock was working on that movie not
one great
it's not the size of your following it's
like how passionate and dedicated you
only need like 500 really dedicated uh
lone gunmen to to change gotham um
yeah exactly that's what they said in a
star is born right yeah yes he's not
even getting to the top of like r slash
gotham like let's be honest
oh man lots to say about that one yeah
get ready for this a couple weeks yeah
it's coming online soon
um
we have deleted scenes perhaps or
deleted jokes anything maybe no
otherwise you can expect what my wife
calls a good old-fashioned paducah river
strangle then i'll leave your body in
the desert under a thousand atari et
cartridges we're not fans of leaving
loose ends amazing how many videos on
youtube there are for how to dispose of
a body dude
i like that little gunner boy
gun haver
lego lad
legolas
thrust a coin to your witcher
knave bautista
all bark no bite
the shining
and
lord have mercer on me
only fans
bad news bards
tragic the gathering
the
mercenaries dungeon masters of the
universe
man this official d d movie is just
chris pine getting warped into the game
jumanji style well that'll suck don't
screw this up pine this is your chance
to become the one true hollywood chris
embrace your destiny
uh so we didn't go with that one because
joe you're now contractually not allowed
to disparage the official duns and
dragons dungeons and dragons movie and
all of its affiliated ip and holding
property now i'm not but as of the video
it was really clunky and i think i just
really wanted to talk about chris pine
being the best chris uh do you think
he's
leaped uh over evans
dude i've always been i've always been a
pine head you always have been on the
pine train
i've always been on the pine tree it's
pine versus evans at this point uh
adamsworth a solid third place
a a nice he collects the bronze he had a
nice effort but yeah
um and we're not even gonna the pratt
who shall not be named uh fourth point
is falling deeply down the leaderboard
it was just a lot of information
um i mean especially now that he's
gandalf
[Laughter]
it was just a lot of information and
opinions and lines to fit into like
an eight-second tag it didn't feel good
i just think you have different rush
hour lines but
never touch a gray wizard's staff i
don't know
working on it
i'll be back with that
uh
okay
uh questions from fans there's some uh
langley neely says congratulations joe
you'll be so missed um
are you are you allowed to ever come say
hi or that do you know if your contract
is like you can't even appear on camera
on anywhere else
i don't no
okay
i don't know yet that's fine
this is all very new
yeah
yeah uh well if if the answer is uh is
you you are allowed to come on to
promote the new addition or whatever uh
you know you won't be a stranger um
and and i'll see your trader joe's also
uh let's see um mr trader joe's man that
is a reference that is for three of us
uh benjamin brownwoods writes how do you
feel about the dnd episode of community
and can you make an australian community
uh it's great and um john bailey
asked for that like
every other week so
yeah we should i mean the problem is
it's really funny and meta and
self-aware like how do you make jokes
about it it was hard enough for fox
machina like yes comedies are tough
especially when they're pretty good it's
actually that because it's so
like it's already so self-aware and like
yeah and stuff is always he's
interrogating his stem cell while he's
writing
so
would be easier or there would be more
material than that literally talk about
community which is just like the town
honestly
yeah or chevy chase or something um yeah
or just the times he does dnd
yeah yeah
but yeah the good good stuff is hard to
do uh and we had a bunch of people in
the comments on this one that are just
like more like dishonest trailer i this
show sucks it's like i well i liked it
and
really so that's i wrote i wrote the
jokes accordingly
are those are those critical role fans
who are disappointed in the show or
those people from outside this world
coming into being like i don't like this
maybe yeah i don't know um but uh yeah i
i think we've always done our best to
just write what we kind of actually
thought about banks so you know and
sometimes we're like ah this was a piece
of crap and sometimes we're like yeah
you know there were parts of it we
really liked but a lot of it we have to
make fun of and for me honestly
i would rather
it's really hard like you said to like
make fun of things that like kind of are
self-aware
i would rather uh
shoot the crap about stuff uh uh that
i'm into that i think is good then pile
on to something that's like super bad oh
really i think i disagree yeah
i definitely i mean in life sure i would
love to talk to friends about stuff i
love yes like obviously yeah right but
writing jokes about something like
honest trailers like next week i won't
spoil it but
much easier to write
well and we have a couple coming up in
the next couple of months if you know uh
the uh release dates are correct yeah
we're gonna dunk all over and dunking is
fun but i do kind of like it it's more
fun for me to be like how do i like
build this puzzle where i figured this
thing out and being like well i'm to
make fun of
or like
because that's like super easy you know
every now and then
yeah i was going to say the the next two
weeks in no particular order is probably
going to be some of the most insulting
and then most complimentary honest
trailers so you'll you'll get a real
diver
so uh let's see um
uh john bainbridge asks what board game
would make the worst movie scrabble and
what would be the best katan
this is it's been talked about a few
times uh like it keeps coming up so i
feel like eventually we will get the
stratego movie but i feel like that's a
board game that was really like born to
be a movie because it's like
old-timey war and it's already kind of
set up to be like an espionage sort of
story like i feel like that one is going
to work better than most
now that i've seen did you all watch
lawn watch the gilded age because we'd
talk about it the gilded age was a
fantastically expensive show where
nothing happened
if they just finale pivoted on whether
or not christine baranski would walk
across the street to her neighbor's
house that's well but that's symbolic of
new money versus old the season one
finale
but all that i bring it up because i
feel like
if you gave me
that approach
to a settlers of catan series that's
just dry as hell and it's just these
people like i'll trade you full pieces
of wood for that sheep like i'd watch it
i i really think i'd watch that very dry
katan movie
just to be sure we're talking about
worst or best both
okay so i i honestly think that like
if we did a mall madness that would
actually be a really fun throwback
um like 80s like thing either mall
madness or like a mystery date i think
those would be either
in the correct time
yeah i mean if you wanted to make
mystery date a scream like thriller i'm
there
like open the door to your mystery date
that sounds terrible you got to answer a
phone to your mystery date nah dude no
no no
it'd be a period
updated it because we kept liking it so
much but the original one was like open
the door to your mission you have like a
phone and then like it's like oh well
your mystery date comes the door again
that sounds [ __ ] terrifying and then
you just like stand still
yeah the shock there isn't that oh go
ahead joe oh mouse trap directed by park
chanwook
okay i like that but it's just
setting it up it's forever like 45
minutes of setup
no it's just one guy in the mouse trap
and he can't get out and he's and it's
horribly violent yeah yeah just i
thought it was worth
for revenge
i think the worst one would be monopoly
because it's just like
sympathize with this landlord for two
hours no it's supposed to show you how
oppressive the and and lose
the system
but the way it plays out is you're just
like it's the fun of role-playing as a
lamp
don't tell daddy is also a horror story
you mean
[Laughter]
because even the commercial was
startling
because it was like a dad and a big
sleepy cat that would
like he was going to start a tick tock
video yeah
you could do like a
like a torture porn operation
like oh some kids end up in the wrong
hospital yeah like you buy roth's
operation yeah
like it's like you gotta get this heart
out of your dad without hitting the
sides like oh no daddy i think cards
against mandy would be terrible um
like are you like a flaming piece of
bacon having i don't know how to how do
you play cards against mandy again i
remember it
you gotta you gotta put cards together
to make like not funny jokes yeah you
make like the most edgy crappy jokes you
could think of it's like i think it's
like apples to apples except apples to
apples is like you have a little bit
funnier yeah you have to be like funnier
so uh that is like apples to apples
where it's just like every answer is
like and then a penis got a it's like
right
it would be like set it like an open mic
comedy night that like they can't leave
like the street charm or the bourgeoisie
style like
existential nightmare you could never
leave the open mic that's the cards
again yeah cards against humanity is uh
is funny for uh middle-aged white guys
who who insist you can't make blazing
saddles anymore right yeah and you're
like why
why can't what did you love about
blazing saddles which parts would you
keep
yeah
yeah anyways uh let's do this let's end
on this uh james bond asks what
celebrity who plays d d would you want
to see animated it's vin diesel isn't it
i would love to see it animated vin
diesel in a in a campaign right or um
who else does it um
he's constantly like super defensive
about it like yeah tough guys play d d
it's like does anybody say yeah that's
joe that's joe that's joe angelo very
proud of being a tough guy david yeah
okay yeah yeah no no vin diesel is just
like i know who i am he's just like
vibing listening to like rihanna singing
along to like uh john legend or whatever
i would
he doesn't have i'd go uh
you know i gotta get one last in two
since this is my last one danielle and i
can talk about wrestling now
xavier woods from the new day plays and
i've got to assume he's made the entire
new day group play so i would watch uh
i would watch there like scooby-doo
meets uh the globetrotters version of
the new day falling into a dnd game
animated i would i would watch that i
i'm just gonna go ahead and put out
there i'm hoping that he played a little
bit as preparation for his role in the
2000s film jeremy iron
oh
yeah let's do that let's do it i have a
ton of people who i'm like i would like
to play i want to play d d with zon
mclaren i think that would be the
coolest person to play dungeons and
dragons with all the reservation dogs
yes give me the whole cast of
reservation dogs to play d d with
uh
i'll say colbert i mean why not um
he did uh he did for red nose day he did
a one-on-one game with matt mercer that
was
genuinely delightful because he hadn't
played in like 15 years or something
and so he's like mercer who's got that
voice you know like launches into the
setup and you just see stephen colbert
just like i don't know like just become
like a
14 year old dork again just like
i miss this so much it's it's really fun
if you haven't seen it yeah i missed the
old colbert oh well uh we have the old
bear jumping around
uh
this has been fun um we're we're almost
out of time uh joe
man what what i know this is like uh
uh quasi goodbye because you already
left the the screen junkies crew for d
and d beyond um many moons ago and uh
clearly did something right because you
just got bought by wizards
by wizards not at the coast but they're
real
yeah they just gave
us blue and like we will trade you for
your strongest joe star and we were like
well i mean we need it so yeah two
fantastic beasts for it that's what they
traded it
uh yeah i hope they pay you in niffler
um
or oh i could have niffler computer
but that's great we're all sad but also
excited um but also uh i hope it doesn't
mean we can't see you again um on camera
because you know we'll see around the
neighborhood
yeah we'll see around the neighborhood
uh i've uh man i don't know this has
been my family for 10 years uh i love
you all very much
and uh
leave it at that uh
yeah ten years to quote jeremy piven in
gross point blank 10 years 10 years yeah
so yeah
amazing uh well only only the best and
brightest ahead um because if they've
got joe starr they can't fail
hey
and uh yeah business cards so you know
please uh please check back in and i
want to see lots more um arcanum behind
you and different uh ephemera from from
a different age where steam powers
machines
yes oh they've they've uh they've given
us some insight into how much free crap
we get so this is going to be a problem
yes
treasure chest
weird green light coming out of it we'll
be like what's in there like nothing
don't even look not the dope just move
all right well uh i guess it's too early
to say where the people can find you
then but i'll say for now you know
joestar on twitter and uh anywhere else
people should uh look for you in the
future you know what still it i i
business as usual so still a dnd beyond
they uh they seem to like what we're
doing and want us to keep doing it
oh well there you go so go to uh youtube
beyond and and all joe starts personal
things and um
uh danielle lon goodbye for a few hours
uh
joe
we'll see you soon um and thank you for
everything and always a pleasure and i
hope we have you back
love you guys see you soon bye
[Music]
you